on peut dire qu'il ya au moins un
avantage à être à milan ces jours ci
alors qu énormément de gens s'inquiètent
de la propagation du coronavirus dans le
nord de l'italie
c'est à dire que vous avez ces belles
places c'est beau monument à peu près
pour vous tout seul si vous regardez les
visages
certains des gens ici portent des
masques mais pas tout le monde il ya des
touristes qui sont ici également
s'il ya moins de gens dans les métros
sur les places dans les restaurants ça
ne veut pas dire que tous les milanais
sont à la maison terrésens fermées par
crainte de de recevoir le virus d'être
contaminé par le corona virus il ya des
vacances scolaires les écoles sont
fermées il ya des congés parce que c'est
le carnaval ce qui fait qu'il ya
énormément de gens qui ne sont pas ici
maintenant il ya des restaurants qui
sont fermées ou qui ferment plus tôt il
ya des cinémas qui sont fermés également
mais les marchés publics sont ouverts
c'est ça peut paraître étrange alors que
le gouvernement dit éviter de vous
rassembler dans des lieux publics
on est allé dans un de ces marchés
publics aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui
sont là un des vendeurs disait je porte
un masque pas pour me protéger moi mais
plutôt pour rassurer mes clients vous
voyez il ya des gens qui sont en public
qui tentent de mener une vie normale
a milan on est passé aussi dans le
chinatown 2001 c'est ici dans cette
ville qui a la plus grosse communauté
chinoise en italie c'est une communauté
qui s'est beaucoup de liens avec la
chine
et eux disent ça fait pas quelques jours
simplement qu'on s'inquiète et convie
les répercussions de la propagation et
des inquiétudes entourant coronavirus on
dit ça fait un mois maintenant qu'on vit
ça c'est à dire depuis que le virus a
vraiment fait son apparition en chine et
qu'il a commencé à inquiéter les gens en
chine d'abord donc on sent qu'on est
injustement ciblé parce qu'on est
chinois et qu'on habite en italie
maintenant dans tout ça vous devez
retenir une chose milan n'est pas une
ville fermée milan et surtout une ville
qui attend un peu résignés qui
patientent en attendant que les deux
semaines passent deux semaines qui vont
qui devrait déterminer en fait que la
plupart des gens ici
n'ont pas contracté le coronavirus ici
avec dumont baron radio-canada milan